thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a robust
wild ride with Stevo this week we've got
the new Jackass star Zack Zack ass
Holmes he's on tour with me doing comedy
he's killing it at comedy and I
suggested a joke for him one that I
heard from Scott Randolph now the joke
goes like this
what is the difference between jam and
jelly
well I can't jelly my dick down
I mean you get the idea but the point
being if I take a Bluetooth tablet I can
jam my wiener wherever I want because
it's hard as a rock yeah that's right
that's why Bluetooth tablets are so much
fun telling you man and if you go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
Stevo you could get an entire month's
supply of Bluetooth tablets completely
for free all you gotta pay is five bucks
for shipping it's that simple baby they
love the listeners with the Wild Ride
podcast so much plus what makes it even
easier you get your prescription all
dialed in right on the website
bluetooth.com you consult with one of
their medical providers do it in no time
flat
boom promo code Stevo an entire month's
supply of Bluetooth tablets are on the
way to you all you got to pay is five
bucks for shipping come on and if you're
wondering are Bluetooth tablet's a lot
of fun
let me confirm they are a whole lot of
fun whole lot more fun than jelly that's
for sure now ladies and gentlemen get
ready for Zack ass and let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen Zach Holmes AKA
Zack ass what's up yeah dude it's been a
long time uh that we've been waiting to
get you on yeah your schedules just been
too busy to make it happen we've uh
we've been on tour
we met we finally got you here we are
thank you for having me yeah and we're
in Arlington Texas where you are going
to be my opener tonight super stoked on
that it's gonna be fun I think we can
safely say that of all the jackass cast
members other than me
you've put the most effort into
developing a comedy act thanks yeah I
mean uh it's something I really sorry
Rachel yeah no Rachel yes yeah
um definitely uh something I really want
to do you know I want to like I'm just
trying to transition more into comedy
stuff in general than like even with
skits and stuff too not just like in
comedic acting and not just like hurting
myself like doing stuff oh yeah weird
let's say not only stand up but
extracurricular filming too Zach stays
pretty busy filming stunts and yeah I
mean I been saying that to you for years
yeah like uh you know we want to wrap
some like crazy gnarly stunt like just
kind of fill it out with some comedy
yeah I remember being really stoked when
uh when I think I flew you out yeah the
the cactus stunt yeah and uh and I was
like you see Zach rolling into this
Cactus patch is super gnarly but we're
gonna make it like kind of funny by
saying that oh Zach's gonna jump over
the whole thing we built a ramp there's
just it was stupid but it was funny yeah
and you measured it yeah
yeah so uh and remember we got Tony Hawk
Tony Hawk is the coolest dude man he's
just down for whatever yeah hey Tony
dude I got my this guy Zach you've never
heard of and he's gonna go crash into
some Cactus can you tell him like oh
dude you're gonna air over it that's
right that was the first time you guys
met when we flew him out to your house
right yeah after and you saw him from
the the firecracker video the
firecracker vest yeah I'm from the
firecracker vest and what was crazy was
that when he when when Zach blew himself
up with the firecracker vest he was
wearing an XYZ hat which was my first
ever sponsor
and uh that was just a weird connection
remember I saw the firecracker vest for
the first time because Tommy Lee posted
it
sir Tommy Lee uh you know it was how I
saw you for the first time and then I
I and yeah and then we got you out there
but um how long had that video been out
before Steve reached out to you
um I don't I don't know I don't think it
was that long it went pretty viral like
um like right off the bat on Instagram
yeah on Instagram and YouTube at the
time too
um
yeah it just and I I had been talking
with with Tommy from XYZ for a while
before that because he was just sending
me merch to where like in all the videos
it was pretty cool yeah it did Super Rad
it is very similar uh in that respect to
how I got started was from Tommy sending
me stuff from XYZ yeah I saw like some
so I saw this documentary uh I think
it's all this Mayhem or something and
they're right they're talking about XYZ
a lot and then I saw a video of you
talking about how like XYZ like helped
you like start out and then I was just
like [ __ ] like that's really cool and
like I didn't really think anything else
of it but then like one day they reached
like the XYZ page to re-share one of my
videos and then I reached then they
reached down and I was just
dude it becomes even more clear that
like uh XYZ played a major role in both
of us getting our start so I fly you out
to to do the cactus thing yeah have you
seen my new book and and I have not yet
I haven't I haven't got to I I've had a
couple people tell me about I've had a
few comments on Instagram saying how
much they like that that part of the
book yeah I mean I told you about it
right yeah you told me about it I just
haven't read it right okay good good
because I got pretty graphic
I got pretty graphic about how here you
know you were this crazy guy I just had
to meet you you know I I set it up as
the the context being that in general
I've not been really uh supportive or
you know not that I'm a hater but like
copycat stunt people like just doesn't
turn me on you know like I'm not there's
not really been like a copycat crew that
that I that I read that I got behind you
know yeah like it was it was you were
the exception to the rule yeah and that
was because what I saw you do was just
so gnarly it was so like it was just
something about it I was like I gotta
meet this guy so I thought I fly you out
I send you into this [ __ ] Cactus and
then like almost as soon as you're
you're out of the cactus with with like
hundreds maybe thousands of cactus
needles all over your body yeah then I'm
just like oh my God this guy's gonna get
[ __ ] staph infection he's like the
the most unhealthy [ __ ] guy I I I I I
I I I extended your trip I brought you
to the [ __ ]
urgent care so like dude help this guy
and and they weren't even concerned
about the the needles all over you they
were concerned about how sunburned you
were right
to shoot yeah I like sun poisoning or
something they said they gave me like a
steroid for my sunburn and they were
just like yeah the needles will come out
with the antibiotics over time and
you'll just have to pull them out like
we can't do that like we're not gonna
pull them out dude I had like a team of
[ __ ] body waxers come over to the
house
waxing his skin hoping that the wax
would pull out the [ __ ] needles like
I was I was starting to freak out like
and and so we're driving home from the
the urgent care and I'm and all of a
sudden I'm just like yeah oh dude Zach
like you know
you you
should start taking care of yourself
dude you know like I'm like you uh you
know like and and then and then I take
it like another step further I'm like
dude the whole world loves uh a [ __ ]
transformation they love like like if
you were to like get healthy like lose
weight like the whole thing then it
would be like a whole other level of
opportunity for you you wouldn't be like
in you know the the narrow pool of
people who want to see like dudes [ __ ]
themselves up like that would open you
up to like Ellen DeGeneres style [ __ ]
like look at this guy he changed himself
and I was like let me [ __ ] help you
get healthy let's bring you bring you
out here so we make this whole plan to
fly Zack out and actually move him to
California to try to help him get
healthy I buy him a [ __ ] car like a
used car
yeah
we're driving off this [ __ ] used car
lot and Zach's just blowing through red
lights
and it turns out oh my God this kid's a
[ __ ] hardcore drug addict
why because he was running through red
lights or what how did that come back it
was like I wasn't even really like high
like when I came again
I'm fine okay I'm totally fine
also I've not had a lot of driving
experience at all like just in general
like no one ever taught me how to
[ __ ] drive like like growing up that
never [ __ ] happened so I am a shitty
driver no no question how'd you pass the
[ __ ] I don't know oh I did you passed
right I passed I passed in Indiana wait
wait so so so I mean dude you were
blowing through I was so nervous like
driving you too because I was like I
don't know it was super like early like
it was like
it was like Mystery Dude like you just
go through red lights and there's a car
like the conversation come up to where
like he was a bad driver over to like
Bridging the Gap of he's on drugs like
it like it just became like it became
that was like the first thing was oh my
God like what's going on with this kid
how did you not see that as a [ __ ]
red light you just blew right there
Steve's telling you you're a bad driver
yeah like I mean like however it became
clear
it became really [ __ ] clear like uh
that what he's on drugs he was on drugs
and then we had and I remember thinking
because because our buddy Tommy's a big
recovery guy like we're all in recovery
and and when it came to our attention oh
Zach's got a problem with drugs
then all of a sudden we thought oh well
we're way better suited to help them
with that so
we like started trying to help you with
that yeah and that didn't go very well
at first no it didn't because you picked
up skateboarding
yeah
at the sober living I was really stoked
on that
um yeah I was skating and then like I
was like it was kind of cool just like I
was like like I was able to drop in I
was doing some other stuff and then one
of my friends was like oh you should do
this rolling grind but I can't like
Ollie so like there's no way I was gonna
get off safely he thought I would just
build it like somehow right off of it
and I just ride down and I fall like two
times before and he's like just try one
more time
and uh we try it I go again and I fall
off weird and my I land like all my
weight on my right leg like falling
backwards leg just snaps in half it was
it was the gnarliest break yeah right I
hate seeing footage like that I'm so
happy I was on the video though at least
like it was like it was your leg Yeah it
was my leg too it would break yeah tib
fib yeah because both bones snapped yeah
both like and it wasn't even just like
one little break like it was like broke
then like under it broke so it was like
there was like a little middle piece it
was just there on each leg
I mean on each uh bone tip him I
remember feeling responsible for that
[ __ ] too I was just like Jesus well that
was definitely me and
then was to the
two that we we put you in a sober living
like a halfway house and we're paying
for it and it was like okay Zach you
know like we're all about recovery and
like in hindsight it was so silly
I'll tell you what's really silly is not
capitalizing on the opportunity to make
money from e-commerce baby like I do and
I'd be slinging my autographed
skateboards at stevo.com you know how I
sling these boards well I use ship
station what's that it's your e-commerce
hub for all your shipping needs whether
you're shipping from Etsy or Amazon your
own website Shopify you name it all of
it it's all at ship station and in one
easy to use interface it brings in all
of your carriers your United States Post
Office your UPS FedEx plus it gives you
the best rates that you can get rates
that are normally reserved for Fortune
500 companies plus you're gonna get that
automatically and what's even better if
you go to ship station dot com Click the
microphone in the top right hand corner
plug in the promo code Stevo you're off
to the races with a 60-day free trial
period That's 60 days two months of
hassle-free
stress-free
ship station baby and with this holiday
ship storm of e-commerce going on man
ship station is saving the day for
everybody like me who's killing it at
e-commerce so
stop blowing it if you got a New Year's
resolution let it be that you're gonna
start crushing it with e-commerce by
going to shipstation.com click that
microphone in the top right plug in the
promo code Stevo and you are Off to the
Races it's time to make ship happen this
year baby now let's get back to it
to to expect that we could just like
push you into that you know like if I
like in mindset if I think about it from
Zach's perspective it's like oh you know
like it's always been you know my dream
to like be like that you know a jackass
guy now I've got like the guy from
Jackass like of course you're gonna tell
us everything that we want to hear you
know of course it was like we were
dangling a carrot and uh you know and
and and of course you're gonna try to
pretend that everything but you just
didn't have it in you at that time no I
wasn't like really ready like to like
get better you know that time but like
looking back like if if that wouldn't
have happened like I wouldn't have like
I wouldn't have I probably wouldn't be
sober right now like so I wouldn't even
know I wouldn't even known about that
stuff or like how to even like fix that
you know right the seed was planted yeah
it definitely helped me like in the end
you know right and then in my book I
talk about how like it you know you
weren't ready but then all of a sudden
like sometime later
uh you just got it on your own the seed
had been planted and then the seed
you know yeah the plant grew and uh and
and you were doing so great
with everything
and then at a certain point it became
well I mean then then Dad you were doing
great when you filmed the movie yeah it
was great during the movie
um but then after like the movie was
like done and everything I started like
I don't know something like things just
like I know you dripped it away yeah
yeah I remember telling you I was like
dude like you know we gotta we gotta
kind of stay involved in all of this
stuff and you're like just kind of
gradually just drifting away and not
paying attention to protecting your
sobriety but I mean it's got to be tough
being on a number one hit movie like how
intoxicating was that for you being on a
red carpet like
whoa everybody knows who I am now I mean
did everybody know who you were
beforehand I mean somewhat but like
because I'm I'm just someone like I'm
sort of recognizable to begin with but I
mean the movie has helped so much you
know like it's it's opened up so much
for me I mean dude Zach was recognizable
as [ __ ] off the back of just the
firecracker vest and then the cactus
video had me do that Cactus video got
hundreds of millions of shoes yeah like
that that Cactus video made you oh super
recognized yeah it did that was like
that helped so [ __ ] much yeah I mean
it's pretty crazy how uh how how that
happened and then um
I mean I don't know like of course a
jackass movie is a big deal too but um
as far as it's got to be tough staying
sober when you're in a number one movie
I mean dude
like
so it's like my guy always said to me
there's only one book there's no special
edition for special people yeah yeah I
mean if you're not special right the
disease of alcoholism and addiction does
not discriminate does not discriminate
and neither does recovery yeah
so uh I mean it's crazy it's so after
the movie happened right after the movie
came out what happened
um I sort of like just well I sort of
just was in a bad spot and like didn't
like I wasn't like I made like some
other like show for like a little bit
with Vinnie that was the film yeah the
fail army thing I did that I did a few
other things you know I ended up doing
Shark Week
um
there was just like a bunch of like
there's a bunch of things here and there
but like I I didn't really like
I was just in a bad spot like because I
was because I was using you know I
wasn't really like capitalizing I'm like
oh I should be like striking while the
Iron's hot right now you know what I
mean like and yeah everything just got
sort of gnarly for me yeah
um do you remember when we uh
the intervention on you yeah I do yeah I
remember that you you talked a pretty
good game I was like we showed up in
your crib yeah
like like we showed up like practically
moments before the eviction notice
showed up
like and uh we were there waiting to
Ambush you when you got home from
something or other we're like hey he's
acting like you know we're worried about
you we want to um offer for you to get
you know to get help and and and make it
completely free for you and you're like
no I'm fine dude I'm totally fine okay
like seriously I'm I'm fine like it did
it was kind of convincing for him I
believe I believed yeah that was cocaine
yeah
I mean it's like when you're doing that
and you could come up on somebody that's
on drugs and they're like convincing but
like your spiders it's like a weird
thing because you're like
you sound convincing but like everything
in my gut is just being like this
[ __ ] guy is lying dude dude I say you
talked a good game but
it was it was it was
well then I was like okay so so so you
mean to tell us that like if we leave
here you don't have if we go in your
house right now there's no drugs inside
and then when you totally looked away
from us and you're like yeah you could
totally do that's fine I was like all
right well they weren't in the house
they were in my pocket
right you know and and uh and and there
was just no getting through to you that
dude I'm totally fine I'm totally fine
it was like okay man you know and then
uh to your credit not too long after you
reached out and said hey man is that
offer still good and uh and man that
that's awesome dude I'm I'm super super
glad what made you call well I mean like
after you guys showed up like it was
like stuck in my head like maybe I
really [ __ ] do need to like go
[ __ ] like get this [ __ ] figured out
you know turned out you needed it pretty
bad yeah like it was just like how long
can I you know keep doing this for you
know and uh well how bad was it when we
showed up dude it was bad it was it was
pretty bad
I mean it was pretty bad
yeah it was it was really really bad and
um did it and it's so cool because
I uh you know had some people who I know
there was one guy who had offered a
scholarship to to me for somebody and I
was like man this is the scholarship
that dude came through with like
I think it was like 60 70 000 worth of
uh free treatment I mean dude that was
yeah and then and then and then uh
continued to with Aftercare all I had to
pay for was the detox
I paid for the Uber yeah thanks guys
medical detox is no joke either dude you
know like uh did you detox pretty good I
mean it was it was fine yeah I mean like
it was good that I was if I wouldn't
have had like the if I wouldn't have
been able to go to the detox it would
have [ __ ] sucked like so bad it was
opiates I mean dude yeah like no no
rehab is gonna take somebody in who's
not been probably yeah yeah cause then
when you die in their care they get sued
yeah yeah what if for those kind of
detoxes it just depends on the drug of
choice and then they give you some sort
of muscle relaxant for the week and yeah
what do they do it just like depends
like mine was it was for opiates benzos
and
cocaine and like and stuff like that
um yeah so they that was like three days
before you said you were fine
got it yeah
I'm totally fine okay big pale white
yeah
seriously there's like literally nothing
wrong
so so that so you detox like a week and
then you got right into the yeah then I
did that stuff and you know did you you
did you detox I was in
um yeah I was I was gonna do tax I don't
know that I was like was it like a what
do they call that medically induced
detox nothing like that nothing like
that I mean the the rehab I went had a
detox in it so it wasn't like I went to
a detox and then a rehab it was just all
built into one place because that's like
if you're like a hardcore Drinker you
want to detox somebody so they don't
like convulse and like have a seizure
yeah and then for for opiates you don't
want like the withdrawal process and you
don't want it I mean it's a medical deal
you know like a dude the detox we sent
Zach to is basically like a hospital
there's a there's doctors there like me
yeah like
um and so what's life like now after
um I mean things are looking so much
[ __ ] better for me honestly yeah
um yeah and I just I don't know I feel
like I get I don't know I have like the
one and like the will like I don't know
I want to do [ __ ] like I want to like
get out there and like make sure to
happen you know like I just feel like so
much better like overall I mean you've
always had that yeah but I mean like
I've always been motivating you've
always been wanting to uh be successful
and and you've always been teachable
like um so I I think I I see good things
for you if you just like I've always
said if you make recovery your number
one priority your only priority
everything else will just come together
yeah everything else doesn't even need
to just just worry about about being in
recovery yeah
uh so tell us about the movie that you
just did are you allowed to I don't even
know if I can it's like a big time movie
star I can say six hours it wasn't I'm
not even like a huge pardon if I hadn't
known about it earlier or had like a
talent manager or something I would have
like or like an agent I would have
auditioned for like a way bigger part
but it was about the 80s Punk scene so I
was in the Bay Area just filming this uh
just being pretty much that's why I like
face piercings right now and like stuff
like that yeah I noticed that that was
just your deal no I had a septum
piercing too but it fell out
um so you got face piercings for a movie
room and you're just stoked on here
rocking it yeah yeah pretty much yeah
I'm down with it yeah
did you have a talking part
um I was like I I was like around like
most of like the main characters and
there were some fight scenes and stuff
that's cool
and then you get another project going
on but you can't really talk about it so
you got [ __ ] going down yeah yeah yeah
like I just did like a voice for a
cartoon and then like I uh I'm I'm gonna
make a movie next year I got cast and a
couple other things too so that's cool
I'm like trying to start acting more
um and just and mainly like acting doing
stand up writing that kind of stuff cool
man yeah
um
and uh
so going back to when the movie came out
yeah like um
were you crushing some beef
no dude you weren't I was not
um but now like you you've got it I I
Vinnie told me that you're in a new
relationship with like a really cool
chick yeah it was like super hot yeah I
have a new girlfriend yeah yeah yeah
she's pretty cool wondering so well
um she just stand up and stuff too she's
uh
is she an army yeah okay normally yeah
all right well that's good man every
person we've had on from the movie I
want to talk about the uh
the science of the Lamb's bit oh yeah
yeah how was that for you that was
[ __ ] terrifying
there could not be a better jackass bit
to test what your heart rate actually
got to and you gotta know there's no
better way to test your heart rate than
with the whoop strap yeah whoop strap
the most sophisticated Fitness device
known to man in the history of the world
it tells you everything that's going on
with your body how much you're working
out how much you're you're resting every
stage of sleep like when you do work out
how much of that workout was spent in
your high heart rate zone like how many
calories you're burning
Tony I love my whoop strap so much and
how many people have we heard on this
podcast talk about how much they love it
I mean dude all of the fighters all of
the
podcasters all everybody it's amazing
and you should try it especially because
now they've got the whoop band 4.0 which
comes with the waterproof charger that
slides around you never have to take it
off you just slide on your charger if
you accidentally get in the shower no
big deal because it's waterproof and if
you go to whoop.com
and just do your thing when you check
out you plug in the promo code Stevo 15
off your membership it's so killer man I
mean
it's definitely worth a shot and it's
definitely at whoop.com so get on there
and find out what's going on with your
body man I wish Zach would have been
wearing a whoop band back then but you
know what
I've got some plans to do some pretty
hellacious stuff myself with my root
band so we'll see what happens we're
gonna get insights into Terror but let's
get back to it yeah it was it was scary
like
um because like you're the only one who
thought there was actually a rattlesnake
yeah I was
um well because initially there was a
rattlesnake in the room
um but then they like they whatever the
animal Handler guy was like took it out
you know because Jeff was being so nice
to me that day and I should have known
like that it like something was about to
happen and he's he was just being really
nice and stuff and then he's like oh um
he's like yeah we need to change your
shirt like I was wearing like a black
shirt or something we need more more
color like in the scene so I go change
my shirt and then I come in you know
they shut the door on poopies and I and
you know it would just goes pitch black
it was [ __ ] terrifying how long were
you in there for I don't know like it
felt like for it felt like an eternity
um but it was just I guess it was
probably like a few minutes
um but they're like [ __ ] with us like
teasing us and stuff and then I like
before this all too like they're telling
us what would happen like if you got bit
by a rattlesnake you know and my anxiety
is like going through the roof just
because I'm like medical stuff it's like
the one thing that'll like make me have
a [ __ ] panic attack and heights yeah
and heights yeah Heights too
um so they're like telling us all about
how your heart will start racing and all
this [ __ ] and like how you end up like
having a heart attack and dying like if
you don't get the anti-venom soon enough
and they I guess it was like Knoxville
or someone comes up to me and puts like
something out it felt like something bit
me I I have no clue what the [ __ ] it was
and then and I'm thinking it's a snake
because they had like a Morocco they had
like Maracas or some [ __ ] like
pretending to be the snake and I started
freaking the [ __ ] out
um and then like I I have no clue how to
get the [ __ ] out of this room and then
Knox like that's the only way out like
well they sort of like pretends to break
character like we need to get him out or
whatever he got bit and then I'm
freaking the [ __ ] out because I'm like
dude I got bent what the [ __ ] is like
what is gonna happen I'm gonna die like
I'm not healthy like I'm not healthy
like it's not gonna like this is how I'm
gonna die or something and then Knox is
like it's the only way to get out and
like pushes me through the door because
I was like afraid to go in there and
there's just Marbles and like pots and
pans and [ __ ] everywhere I slit my shoes
the one who climbed over the counter
yeah yeah there's like a thing like
guard the camera people and there's like
all this stuff on it to make sure you
wouldn't go there like thumbtacks and
mouse traps and [ __ ] and I saw that like
because that stuff was on there that was
the way to go and I just climbed over
and [ __ ] yeah I just cut myself up so
if there was hell that would be it
probably yeah that felt like one of the
levels of hell
it's crazy dude and you were in there
with poopies yeah I was in their poopies
how often are you in contact with
poopies these days
um not a lot we were talking about maybe
making some YouTube stuff like a few
weeks ago but I haven't talked to him
since
yeah
um definitely would like to do that that
would be fun yeah I think uh I would I
would be careful about
um having like a sober
crew with you yeah yeah if you're gonna
yeah yeah I think every no matter what
you're doing it's either protecting your
sobriety or it's endangering your
sobriety yeah and hanging out with
poopies I think might and thank you
you're right
we can cut it out later but uh
hearing from bam is he okay is he in the
hospital still do you want he's out of
the hospital is that the hospital that's
good and uh it just tells me I actually
have a text that I haven't read yet
so should I see what uh
that I mean to be put on the ventilator
I can't believe I I told him everyone
was worried as [ __ ] about you you okay
now and he wrote I can't believe I'm out
and better I was a dead man on Elvis
birthday
[ __ ] I didn't even think about the Elvis
thing why what's it no I was just
listening
know what Elvis's birthday is I still
don't know what it means
good he's better I mean [ __ ] dude
like I shouldn't say this
but but I was like but maybe you
shouldn't I was I was like [ __ ] man
don't [ __ ] die and screw up my tour
yeah I mean that's pretty good so you're
doing stand-up we'll change the subject
you're doing stand-up tonight yeah yeah
I'm standing up tonight are you nervous
um I always get a little nervous but
it's always it's always fun to get up
there and when it starts you know you
start doing it how much time you got in
you
um I don't know I probably I should
probably just do like 10 minutes or
something just to start it off I think
uh 10 10 is good
um are you still doing your better help
joke yes I am
did you did you hear I forget what
podcast it was but I was giving you
praise for that oh no I didn't that's
sick I think it might have been the Ari
shaffir podcast
sorry I don't know maybe it was one of
the jackass guys but uh yeah that joke
is great oh yeah I love that one it's a
good one do you want to give a special
shout out to Howie Mandel and apologize
for not calling him back
um not really
yeah I thought that was funny whatever
you were supposed to call however no he
like I did his podcast and then like it
was just like I ended up walking out
like I was like gonna leave I don't know
if you remember when he you'll see you
pranks me or whatever and then um
podcast and and I pranked you yeah yeah
you pranked me on there and then that
was like the first thing where I was
like
God damn it like I [ __ ] like I was
like I hate highway right now and then
he had me in his podcast and then
Knoxville calls in and does like a
similar like thing and like gets mad at
me for being like yeah and then I like
freaked the [ __ ] out and I was like dude
I'm going I was like I'm out of here I'm
[ __ ] done and I just walked out of
the podcast and then they like coerced
me to come back in and I had to finish
the podcast
and we are on the podcast together so I
sort of had to go back in was Rachel in
on it too no well she like Knoxville
called and said like we didn't get it
clear to a Paramount to go on there and
promote the movie which I didn't
actually even think about being a thing
but Rachel had already done that but I
had not
um and and then they turned it into this
whole like thing like it was like a way
bigger deal than it was so you fell for
the same [ __ ] [ __ ] I pulled on again
yeah yeah it was just another Paramount
thing reloaded no I was not I was I was
sober
ah all right so uh so you're gonna crush
it tonight during stand-up yes
I hope and then do you have any dates
coming up after this
um I'm doing a show with Rachel and Matt
on Sunday
and in LA
and then I think I I'm doing one in
Huntington Beach in January and then
like there's probably going to be a
bunch more that stuff just randomly
happens you know right
um
and let's talk about your uh your
YouTube and stuff um you've had your
channel like deleted by YouTube because
you put such gnarly stuff on there yeah
yeah but that's how it was initially
um
I had you know I was just posting like
really gnarly stuff and some like
because I wasn't there was like no
comedy like based around it at all it's
just gnarly [ __ ] and like it just was
just literally just dangerous activities
which is like against YouTube policy so
uh yeah I ended up getting terminated
like a while back and then but then I
built a channel yeah yeah I have that
one still I've not been posting at all
really recently I was posting Vinnie and
I's podcasts on there though and we're
gonna start that back up in January and
then I have some idea like we we talked
before about video ideas for me like
different things dude yeah I got you to
pull out your notepad we came up with a
bunch of killing ideas and you haven't
made a single goddamn one of them I mean
I filmed the the top like the top like
five or top 10 like worst injury thing
um I just never put it up that's
probably gonna run into problems yeah it
definitely is that was the one reason I
didn't want to like Put it Up filmed the
one thing that that I can't post
now we made a good list for you yeah
what is your top one
can you yell at Zach about uh your exact
website
I'm I'm kidding dude
you called me with him on the phone and
I was like Zach
I have your website you remember all you
have to do is click accept
that's all you had to do was just go it
was built we built your website I know
um here's the thing yeah no I don't know
dude I was like
at that time I was like freaking out
about like I mean I wasn't really
freaking out but I was like I was just
like not wanting like I don't know I
didn't want to do like sun stuff as much
and I was like what does that do with
the website
that's what the website is we were
telling you Zach like you're a principal
cast member and a major theatrical movie
release yeah Paramount Pictures and it's
time to get organized yeah take
advantage of the opportunity that this
is going to represent for you yeah and
for this movie to come out and you to
not have a website would be blow you'd
be blowing it got it you gotta be ready
before the movie comes out you gotta be
ready have your website you should have
some merch ready to go you should be
like have a bunch of content lined up to
just keep the momentum going with and we
got you covered Zach we got you a
website we bought you zackass.com like
we built it for you we're ready to hand
over the range to you all you gotta do
is click accept
oh my God and and now the movie came out
a year ago yeah Zach says dude I'm gonna
take care of it
dude I'm totally gonna do I'm gonna be
on it
you have it and all you gotta do is
click accept yeah we can get that taken
care of and then if you go if you and
Vinnie are doing a podcast in January
yeah you can house everything there and
yeah I think that it's it's tough like
when we started with the podcast we were
really careful to keep the podcast on a
different Channel than the main Channel
content because I think that the
algorithm really views like long ass
podcasts for maybe retention falls out
like we wanted to keep like the keep it
separate and I think that it's possible
that you did a disservice to the YouTube
channel by putting the podcast on your
main YouTube channel that doesn't mean
that that uh that it's a wrap no big
deal but every one of those ideas that
that you and I put on your your path
yeah
yeah I mean those those will all perform
really well yeah I know they will yeah
they definitely will yeah and it's only
been like a year and a half since we did
that
what's what's the problem though like
finding an Editor to edit the videos
I don't think you want to uh
literally fine
at the time though I was not motivated
to [ __ ] do anything when all that
stuff was going on like I literally
wasn't like why not what step was going
like it's like no like having like when
you guys are giving me the website and
all this stuff I wasn't doing anything
and I wasn't like I was not like in the
mental headspace to even make content
didn't we get didn't we like get designs
made for him for Merch too yeah
until we did everything for you I know I
mean that just goes to show but I but I
think like you know just in general when
it like for for filming your own stuff
like I don't even think I think you
should just focus on filming and and
sourcing out the editing just that way
it's like it's done for you and I think
what most people get lost in the Weeds
about is like it's like having you know
it's it's when a CEO takes over business
and he's doing everything it's like I
think you're in a place to where you can
have an editor do this you can have a
film or you don't need to be all three
right I I think that what it is as well
is that it's just daunting when it's on
you to
film it to write it to edit it like it's
just such a mountain of work where
if you find the right editor then that
person can help facilitate the filming
and then and everything and just make it
easier it's kind of like uh
like with with my with my girl you know
I um
you know before I met my girl and I was
just running around like being
distracted and you know like wasting all
this time chasing chicks around there
was a nightmare and then like by
stopping chasing chicks around then I
find a girl who actually helps me
accomplish stuff come on you know in in
this case skinny Vinny can be your girl
Vinnie is uh Vinnie is a godsend Vinnie
get over here and steal this mic
like uh Vinnie is uh you guys what's up
dudes yeah have a seat can you fit next
to Zach yeah there you go dude now tell
us your relationship with Zach and and
how it started so we met what five years
ago now yeah in sober living yeah yeah I
recognized who he was
um from the cactus video yeah yeah and
uh
you asked me to be your filmer yeah and
I started filming for him for about a
year yep and then uh it was just like
one thing after another yeah yeah
um why not you know what I want to do
can we bring in uh another mic for
Vinnie yeah I'm stoked
Vinnie on here
well can we talk about what we're doing
while they're setting up or do you want
to just cut it how are we gonna explain
oh I guess we've already brought
Brittany on we brought Vinnie on here we
brought vignon
he's already done enough as it is
I love Vinnie she's Kevin Zach are a
[ __ ] a heart attack pretty funny
though like uh all you have to do is
click accept
he's like I know
I literally know
I was on his ass for so long about this
no no here's the thing because I
remember Steve you called me up with him
on speakerphone you're like hey dude can
we build Vinnie a website for the for
the movie I'm like Steve
the website's already built it's done
I've been trying to get you to train
I've been trying to get you to like
transfer ownership over it
and then you're like I know but
here we are now
it's good though because uh
I think you can still do it yeah
you can totally still do it dude
and it's been fun to talk about all this
stuff just because it's not like on a
timeline right like yeah yeah is there
anything that you're tripping out about
are you good no it's all good all right
so so where were you so we met almost
five years ago right right and then you
started filming for him yeah I started
filming for them and uh
the first video was the uh the boxing
glove bit yeah we attached a boxing up
to an RC car that's one of those to go
like 50 miles per hour yeah yeah and we
went to Venice Beach and uh
the video did really well and that was
the first video I filmed for him and I
used to film videos back in the day Andy
used to do Andy Roy's podcast Rip Ride
yep you were like
set up kind of in a behind the camera
like producer capacity editing producing
and only with Zach did you
like get in front of the camera yeah the
first time I got in front of the camera
he pranked me and uh he like did an
antique on me and then we went to bams
for that party and I got recognized from
that one video and I was like oh that
felt really good right so that's when I
wanted to start making my own content
right and I bring this up because when
you started getting in front of the
camera then you and Zach Together made
this this uh fail army show and then he
started doing the podcast together like
you're you're a kid in a candy store you
love everything about it every second of
it yeah and then Zach relapses and then
you're you're in this then you're in
this position where everything that
you're really jazzed about is a hundred
percent hinged to Zach and so you're in
this like this crazy situation where you
want to keep doing the in front of the
camera stuff but like you can't you
can't for sure and when you told me
after we had that intervention with them
you're like dude you gotta stop filming
with them no more show no more podcasts
I was [ __ ] pissed when you told me
that because I was like Pastor bummed
bummed super bummed pissed at Steve no
not oh I could see that because there
was a little resentment towards you
totally get pissed when somebody tells
the truth you know it's like [ __ ] and it
made sense but like At first I was
bummed because I was like oh dude it's
so easy for you to say that right like
just say no to a second season a decent
paycheck you know
and then I talked to you about it and I
was like [ __ ] dude what do I do and then
when we had that conversation at the
warehouse
it just made sense you know what I mean
and I was bummed but it was like
I have to you know right and uh so well
there was a point when I forget which
one of you guys posted but there was
some podcast clip and Zach was so loaded
on it and it was just like and and I was
like hey yo dude like what's up with
this dude like and and you texted me
right away yeah I texted you right away
and and Vinnie says oh dude yeah man
like Zach was loaded man we didn't put
up that whole podcast you know I'm like
what about this one clip
the funny thing was you know like I just
had a feeling you were gonna text me too
and I was like and I was thinking about
taking it down and then you just beat me
to the punch and texted me and I was
like [ __ ] or delete it
yeah do you know what it's talking about
Zach no I'm not sure
instances yeah well were you high on
most of the uh podcasts I mean after a
while yeah yeah how many podcasts did
you guys do we had 25 episodes and
you're a high of 24 of them
it was like after the 10th episode is
when I started realizing okay but it was
more of me like giving him the benefit
of the doubt sure I mean it's crazy how
us addicts are the easiest [ __ ] to
fool half the time yeah yeah yeah yeah
and uh and then I even think I brought
it up to you once and brought up to you
once and right I'm like dude I think
Zach's getting loaded what made you
think that just uh like everything just
starts like a handful of pills
I've known Zach for like since sober
living days where he was struggling in
the house a little bit and then I knew
him when he was got sober and was doing
great and then I start to see [ __ ]
decline like personal hygiene [ __ ]
the like just every single habit right
and but here I go again just like just
here I go again just like giving them
the benefit of the doubt right and when
that one particularly disturbing clip
went on your Instagram that was before I
was like hey man you can't [ __ ] with
Zach that was before yeah right yeah so
like to put into perspective like what
you had become okay with was just not
okay you know for sure yeah and and I
understand completely that you could be
resentful and be like yeah hey man it's
easy for you to say that yeah but dude I
was I was upset dude like I was upset
for a few reasons one obviously because
my best bro is like like he's going
downhill again you know and like I'm
just like in the middle of it and I'm
seeing everything just [ __ ] crash and
like everything that we're doing is just
like declining and and then you're
telling me dude you gotta [ __ ] cut it
out and you know you can't [ __ ] film
with them anymore because you're
enabling them sure and like it that
makes total sense now in hindsight but
in the moment I was just [ __ ] well
it's crazy because like the you know one
of the principles that we follow is like
just trust God in all your Affairs and
so like when you cut when you cut that
out and that that cut your finances
significantly right and you're like [ __ ]
what do I do but then wait wait since no
no but but because that was like one of
the biggest fears that you had was like
what am I gonna do for work for sure and
then once you did do that have you made
more money without them or with I don't
know know that there was ever a lot of
money coming in from the stuff that
you're doing his major fear was like
[ __ ] my income but Vinnie's bread and
butter has always been behind the camera
I've made more money behind the camera
than in front of the camera without Zach
yeah yeah for sure yeah 100 yeah Benny's
bread and butter what Vinnie's good at
is working in a a production capacity
yeah a producer like and um
like
he's such a valuable team member to us
and I got to tell you man it feels
really good to have you on a mic
honestly on the podcast yeah yeah yeah
when we had that conversation after he
went into this sober living or the rehab
and you were like dude what do you want
to do yeah he's you're like I know you
got that show and you got that little
tiny Taste of Fame and if anybody's
Addicted to Fame it's me but like dude
you're valuable behind the camera and I
like thought about that for so long and
like
besides Zach dude we don't have many
people to film with you know like close
Bros right you know so it's like
I went back to the production side of
things and I've been [ __ ] the past
like six months have been killer yeah
yeah and to be clear too I never said
give up on your journey oh for sure I
said by all means pursue everything do
everything but just recognize like what
what it's gonna
like what's gonna pay the bills yeah you
know like if you the more you can do
behind the camera to get your bills paid
then the more opportunity you have to
pursue the Ultimate Dream whatever you
want that to be yeah and that's what
I've been looking at I'm never gonna
tell anybody not to no you said it word
for word you're like I will never tell
you to stop chasing your dream you said
that yeah for sure and dude and I love
it man and like it's just really really
rad like how you've been
solid in your program you know that's a
great recovery like yeah
dude I mean you said it first dude it's
like you have to put it first or else
everything just hits the bed and I'm
totally I totally recognize that and
if I lose that I lose all this you know
and that's your last shirt I want to
[ __ ] lose you know were you pissed at
Vinnie for for having the intervention
on you not really I mean I understood
yeah that was such a heavy day did you
guys have a conversation about like hey
man I I got a [ __ ] not do season two
of fail army I got we can't do the
podcast anymore no it kind of fell fell
through on its own
um just like because Zach spoke up and
said hey I I want well that that too
yeah I mean that wasn't why we're not
doing that like
um I mean like like that stuff just
isn't happening yeah just a lot of
things changed over a lot of things
changed over there as a company yeah
um but you know
um that would probably still be on the
table if that stuff didn't happen yeah
yeah it was like the podcast and the
show were like the only things that I
had going on you know and then once the
podcast was done and even though the
podcast wasn't doing great and we were
still so new for only having 25 episodes
we were doing pretty good you know and
uh and like I just love the whole
production and creativeness behind it
and sure that podcasts are my thing so
it was like watch your head what the
hell was that it was dope being able to
to do that now sorry I didn't mean the
the TV was coming out I didn't mean to
cut you off
so you guys have the so the so it's safe
to say that the podcast is going to come
back in January yeah we think so yeah
did you guys have a Chris Markovich on
we did yeah how was that it was rad dude
yeah I grew up watching him skate yeah
it was Super Rad we had him on Rip Ride
back a couple years ago right right yeah
man Chris Markovich was a hero to me
yeah you guys still keep in touch with
Andy nah he unfollowed me for some
reason yeah I think it's because I'm
still homies with Priya
yeah
well
that's what happens
Jenny's killing it Zach's [ __ ] fired
up and ready to go he's gonna click
accept any money now
yeah
you've got a good guy here to help you
[ __ ] get [ __ ] popping dude you guys
make a great team
yeah it's uh it's hard to get him
when he was going through all that [ __ ]
it was like tough being able to be like
all right dude this is the [ __ ] that you
need to do like I'm here like I have all
this equipment in our [ __ ] office
like I'll edit I'll do everything but it
was just it was just hard because he was
just going through [ __ ] and now he's a
new man look at him
he's ready to [ __ ] go yeah are you
gonna are you gonna revamp the uh the
firecracker vests no dude how badly
injured oh it was like second and third
degree burns yeah I'm not gonna do that
again you're not gonna do boxes there's
like no reason for me to do that unless
like I was getting like and there's like
the risk and reward isn't like enough
for me to do it on my own accord you
know yeah
um which if I was getting paid like a
lot of money I would do it again really
but not right now how much would you do
it for right now if I give you 10 grand
would you do it
um I don't know about 10 grand 20.
I don't
know
what's your what's your specialty
because like Steve's is like jumping off
of heights in the shallow pools
Knoxville's Bulls yours would be
um
I don't I don't know I think it's just
funny seeing me or try anything that a
bigger person wouldn't do that's cool
you know so there's a lot of like fit
into a wetsuit that you guys have lost a
bunch of weight yeah yeah I have how
much weight have you lost
um like 100 pounds since the movie wow
yeah I remembered like through the
course of the movie like you got bigger
and bigger man it was like it was
alarming yeah yeah especially like
considering like being that big and and
you're just like oh yeah dude like that
was cocaine and downers
yeah just speed ball City at like
[ __ ] 400 pounds yeah no it was like
460. 460. yeah
Jesus you were speedballing your ass off
at 406 yeah if you're like you have to
choose one like drugs are being fat
so you've been working out and you're
yeah you're slimming down yeah I mean
there's still a lot more work to do
obviously but you know I'm definitely
eating healthier and working out yeah
cool dude when you were in that sober
living way back in the day when we first
moved you out here yeah like when you
put them in the wetsuit and they'll do
the workout video
there was no kids acting you're gonna be
like you know in a food program and and
they were like dude yo Zach's bedroom
is just a mountain of candy wrappers
right it was a mountain of candy what's
your go-to candy
um
I don't
um like Reese's Cups probably are like
Steve that's yours too recently oh my
God and then by the way I'm off the
rails again yeah
why what are you eating
I've been pretty gnarly dude like uh
yeah me too
dude food's the toughest one man yeah I
mean you have to eat so yeah yeah but
it's just like picking the right things
right so crazy man like I'll be
I'm a pendulum with my food man it's
gnarly but you know you I came in here
you had your shirt off and I'm like but
how you still ripped like you're still
skinny
I I don't know about ripped
and I only just like uh went out
you know I'm like I'm only I'm only like
uh
a couple weeks into the only thing I can
think about is how you've always
maintained being so skinny is that that
trial drugs they did on you to like keep
pigs lean muscle well
that's got to be the reason why you're
so lean because I've seen you eat and
it's like I've never seen anything like
it before when you're eating it's like
you're having three brownies with ice
cream and you're [ __ ] eating a whole
pizza it's like I can eat the same thing
gain 50 pounds you just stay thin and I
think that medical [ __ ] that you
experiment with worked when I was 19
years old I did an experimental medical
study for drugs for pigs and cows and
the purpose was to like make pigs lean
yeah like lean muscle all right here
let's get back on track here and let's
come up with the game plan let's click
accept let's get to your website yeah
all right if you see Zach on the street
you're gonna ask him if he has his
website he's gonna say hell yeah I do
okay yeah well dude I love you I'm glad
you're in a good place yeah it has
Instagram oh I'm still cranking on there
yeah I mean we got you that too yeah
what the [ __ ] was your stupid Instagram
handle before I got it it was like tstdm
it was like Trey real like tstd or
something underscore like yeah yeah four
eight hyphen yeah yeah
but yeah Instagram's cool
um it's been it's going well I need I
need to keep posting more but like you
can it's kind of cool you can make money
from uh reels now which is pretty sick
and you can like like it's pretty good
so I definitely need to do that cool man
take advantage of it I don't think I
make money off reels on Instagram yeah
you can like there's like you have
there's a couple different well there's
a couple different ways to monetize on
Instagram now and it's like I'm
definitely taking advantage of that now
yeah good I know Vinnie's down dying to
plug his Instagram too
skinny Vinny at skinny Vinny dude that's
it easy peasy yeah easy yeah yeah dude
Vinny's a huge asset to the team and uh
just stay lazy because we want to keep
them to ourselves
[Laughter]
thank you
good yeah that was good
how about that ladies and gentlemen is
Zach not the most endearing lovable guy
I mean come on you know what you should
do is check out his YouTube channel
we're gonna link the YouTube channel and
Zach you know what while you're sleeping
tonight on the bus I'm not gonna [ __ ]
jelly my dick into your face that's for
buckets
foreign
[Laughter]
yeah dude thanks everybody
[Laughter]
all right